et maintenant j'accueille gaspard proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vu ce qui se passe en turquie ah ouais
c'est mort ouais fenerbahçe rattrapera
jamais galatasaray
ce qu'ils sont à 71 contre 61 il reste
un match à jouer contre casting pas ça
mais comme barys bazda vient de se
prendre un carton
[ __ ] darby 3 bon faut dire que
l'arbitrage était pas au niveau de ce
qu'on a vu en karabükspor et mais chic
tâche ouais franchement mais m hugues du
deuxième est qu'ils feraient mieux de
bosser dans baby foot quoi les mecs qui
se cognent à faire des sauts périlleux
et lui laisse jouer franchement vivement
le retour sur les terrains d'un mec
intègres et compétents comme aux usa non
exécutive n'est pas grave parce que oui
parce que oui qu'est-ce qu'un oui
turquie bien sûr vous attendiez que je
vous parle de la révolution de la place
turc la la la révolte des sens capable
le printemps salades oignons tomates je
suis de harissa mais pas trop j'ai des
hémorroïdes
[Applaudissements]
internationale
parekh sénat ce qui arrive est très
drôle il paraît qu'ils utilisent aussi
des gaz en syrie ce qui veut dire que
dans ce monde et encore des manifs
contre le mariage pour tous
moi je comprends que la communauté
internationale hésite à intervenir sur
avec les gars c'est pas très dangereux
là on récupère assez vite je veux dire
aujourd'hui à gambades christine boutin
n'a rien
théorie de l'évolution féminité sport
roland garros l'endroit où les nageuses
est-allemand découvre les activités sur
sol dur
des étoiles le tennis moi tu sais moi
jeu c'est un sport de riches jeu moi
j'ai essayé ça coûte une blinde entre
l'inscription dans un club l'achat du
matériel la location des types qui
viennent ramasser les balles
[Applaudissements]
non retraite on parle de réformer le
mode de calcul des retraites des
fonctionnaires et parce que dans le
privé on calcule sa retraite sur 25 ans
dans le public c'est sur les six
derniers mois on voit pas ce qu'il ya un
juste pas comme si sur 25 ans un
fonctionnaire travailler plus que six
mois
[Applaudissements]
allocations familiales on parle de les
diminuer pour les enfants c'est
dramatique pas à cause de ça dans de
nombreuses familles pauvres les parents
pourront plus acheter l'alcool pour
pouvoir les supporter
[Applaudissements]
au s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
l'intelligence est ici alors
les allocations j'ai vu ses 450 euros
par enfant quand tu pense qu'une
professionnelle touche deux fois plus
juste pour simuler leur création c'est
pas
famille toujours des familles roms ont
été expulsés de lille aurait vivait le
long des voies de chemin de fer c'est un
peu la [ __ ] à rome c'est comme ça c'est
toujours très arty ferrailleurs quand il
ya un côté l annonce immobilière typique
des roms ces grands espaces de 400
mètres carrés aménagé selon convenance
parquet en terre battue dit pointe de
bucarest
proximité toute commodité des charges
bretelles autoroutes voies désaffectées
animaux domestiques accepté chiens chats
c'était philo coque
médecine toujours
le nombre de médecins étrangers va
continuer à augmenter le patient va
enfin pouvoir reprendre le pouvoir sur
le médecin te voir la question est-ce
que vous avez une carte vitale on pourra
toujours répondre et vous vous avez
votre carte de séjour
bien sûr la grande la grande question
que se posent tous les éditorialistes c
est ce qu'ils seront capables de soigner
les maux franco-français la dépression
la détestation de soi le vote socialiste
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup se forme en roumanie c'est très
exigeant en conformation attention on
des transplantations impressionnante les
mecs qui savent remplacer un rein par un
moteur de clio s'est très
mais tin toujours michael douglas a
déclaré que son cancer de la gorge était
due à une mst choper à cause d'un
cunnilingus week le cunnilingus
donnerait le cancer de la gorge
je profite de cet espace j'ai une pensée
émue pour tous les canards de bain qu'il
faudra envoyer en chimiothérapie
[Applaudissements]
scientifiquement scientifiquement ça a
été prouvé c'est à dire que l'orgasme
féminin causé par voie buccale et
dangereux contrairement à l'orgasme
masculin qui est extrêmement simple
mois alors moi je dis ça c'est juste
c'est juste pour informer c'est pas du
tout pour même si c'est le devoir du
comique de s'engager sur les vrais
sujets les chés tu mets avaler préserve
[Applaudissements]
et tout ça ça a des effets il paraît que
les différences de salaires dans un
couple ont des répercussions sur la vie
conjugale ouais puis si la femme gagne
plus le mec à des problèmes d'érection
et consomment plus de viagra non bah je
commence à mieux comprendre les
relations franco allemand
forcément quelque chose
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
amour toujours dsk aurait essayé
d'embrasser une journaliste italienne à
la fin des années 90 dsk il est plus
fort que la drogue du violeur qu avec
lui les victimes se réveille dix ans
après quoi
plus que cinq ans et anne sinclair porte
plainte pour mariages forcés
municipal finalement nkm sera opposé à
hidalgo or selon patrick buisson nkm
serai à paris la meilleure pour perdre
vu que dans le camp d'en face ils ont
mis la moins bonne pour gagner là
peut-être ses chances
mais la vraie info
la vraie info c'est qu'en 2014 ce sera
forcément une femme qui sera maire de
paris hâte de voir la couleur du nouveau
papier par dans le métro
non non non c'est pas sexiste
franchement une femme ne peut pas ne
peut pas gérer une mary ann opel ne peut
pas non mais
mais si
elles n'ont aucune autorité qu'est ce
qu'une femme sait faire dans une mairie
dire oui à son âme
c'est bien sûr
pas est-ce que ça c'est vu une grande
ville gérée par une femme soit nulle
part dans le monde peshawar kirkouk
kaboul médine faire un moment faut être
sérieux on va vous dire est ce qu'il ya
une bonne nouvelle quand même cette
semaine louis la vente de poppers est à
nouveau autorisé ouais enfin une
conséquence bénéfique du mariage pour
tous qui ne profitent pas qu'aux gains
alors pas belle la vie et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux